there's so many different directions we
can take there are so many different
things we can say but let's begin chris
with your all-time favorite nfl
quarterback and the way he possibly will
react to the green bay packers draft for
2020. considering all the picks they had
and let's show them for the fun folks
watching at home all of the draft picks
that the green bay packers had there
they are and you see the two little
letters before each guy's name that's
the position
that the player plays and i would like
to think that going into the draft aaron
rodgers was hoping for at least two
of those guys to have w and r before
their names but no
not a single w not a single r except for
the r in rb aj dylan who is not a pass
catching running back their second round
pick look chris between taking a
potential successor for aaron rodgers
the first night of the draft and they
moved up four spots and gave up their
fourth round pick to make that happen
taking a running running back in round
two taking a blocking tight end in round
three and not a single receiver the
entire three-day effort what's rayon
rogers supposed to think right now
well
i i think he's supposed to think what he
always always has been thinking which is
wow it looks like i'll be carrying the
team as usual i mean that that's kind of
what he's looking at you know i think
again they've shown
great confidence in his ability
by the fact that they kind of cheat the
support system around aaron rodgers at
times because they know he's so talented
that they go i believe that they go well
he'll get it done with lesser receivers
we don't need to necessarily waste all
our top assets on supporting that
because we think he's so great he can
make it happen yeah that's fine but it's
tremendous pressure on him all the time
and as we've seen you know when they get
in certain shootouts against certain
teams a lot of the nfc championship game
or other things they don't have the
weaponry to keep up so hey i don't know
any other way to say it the draft was
troubling to me in a lot of different
ways for the green bay packers i mean
one i don't know how you could have gone
through this draft and not addressed you
know again the run defense i know i've
been banging on the table for that but
it was 120 yards per game last year it
was 23rd in football almost any good
offensive line that played them moved
them around at will so between you know
not addressing some players around aaron
rodgers and now
uh the deep not addressing the defense
you know and i understand there were
some other things they did well here in
this draft but i just i don't really get
the plan of attack in general i don't
yeah to not use a single pick on a
receiver almost feels like a message of
sorts and i don't want to read too much
into it but they didn't draft a single
receiver and that's what aaron rodgers
wanted he made the comment last week
they haven't used a first round pick on
a skill position player in 15 years and
they finally did it just wasn't a
running back a receiver or a tight end
it was a quarterback and here is what
brian goodkins had to say in the
aftermath of rounds two and three when
they continued to beef up the running
game gudekun said i think matt leflore
has talked to you guys repeatedly about
how much he'd like to run the ball and
have the pass work off of that matt
really wants to tie everything to the
run game and off the run game and these
guys will help us
do that and look we saw how
a potent running game can help you win
single elimination contests in the nfl
that's what the 49ers did to the packers
they ran roughshod all over the packers
and like you said no effort to improve
the run defense no effort to improve the
passing game and this is more of a
long-term effort to improve the running
game not anything that's going to happen
immediately it has to be frustrating if
you're aaron rodgers it has to be
frustrating if you're a packers fan and
look i understand at some point you have
to trust goody koontz and you have to
trust matt lafleur and you have to trust
mark murphy the ceo
but i think for fans sometimes it's a
little bit harder than others when you
look at
where they finished last year
what did them in and whether or not
they've done anything
to get over that san francisco hurdle
right i mean i think those are real
questions let alone you know
you have a quarterback who i don't think
anybody would argue is still one of the
five best quarterbacks of football i
don't care where you put them in that
top five but i don't think anybody's
gonna argue that you know i always say
you know russell wilson desean watson
mahomes lamar jackson aaron rodgers
those are the top five guys in the game
right now you know what all those other
four quarterbacks that i named in that
top five have
they have like talented receivers guys
that scare the crap out of you you know
and i know the houston texas trade away
one of them but they still got two other
guys that are kind of scary and then
traded and got another one for brandon
cooks so
to me it's almost just like disrespect i
i can totally understand aaron rodgers
being frustrated here hey aj dylan the
running back in the second round he's
he's a specimen he's a real power back
does he bring value to the offense
certainly the tight end you mentioned in
the third round the kid from cincinnati
you know he's at hvac they're trying to
find kyle use check right that type of
player tight end full back move them
around do those type of things
but but i just i guess i just don't
understand you know again the the lack
of support system around aaron rodgers
at times to just to accentuate the
greatness of him and make um people so
scared of your offense if you just gave
him one more weapon it would bring that
packer offense to that level and now
it's kind of just like oh they're good
yeah i like it but man aaron's gonna
have to pull you know a few rabbits out
of the hat a few times during the year
the recognizable names from the
receiving core include devante adams
devin functions he's a newcomer jake
kumaro alan lazard darius shepard
academia st brown and marquez valdez
scantling the problem is
one or two of those guys is always hurt
right you never get the full healthy
compliment of the receivers and that's a
separate issue altogether but there are
no names there other than atoms that
will strike fear and i think for a
quarterback like aaron rodgers to do him
justice you need to have more than one
guy like that and to have 36 receivers
drafted 36 receivers a year in which
ravens gm eric decosta said you could
find a starting receiver in round five
how do you not just throw a dart on at
least one of these guys just so you can
go back to your franchise quarterback
and say
we like this guy we think he's going to
make us better and we're trying we're
trying to make you receive more better
right i mean you know again it's not
that it has to blow you out of the water
but we we used to sit here and go man
tom brady's weapons aren't that great
and it was julian edelman and rob
gronkowski were on the the roster i mean
aaron rodgers would get down his knees
and kiss people's feet to have those two
as receivers right now you mentioned the
names devonte adams certainly an awesome
receiver we know that but after that it
is a lot of unproven commodities there
you said it alan lazar and he showed
some glimmers last year valdez
scandling he's shown some you know
spotty spotty goodness here and there
devin funchus he was a little
underwhelming with the carolina panthers
he went to the colts last year got a big
chunk of money he got hurt he didn't get
the show he is a guy that i do think
will have value on this football team
certainly but yeah i just don't know if
there's anybody there that scares you
the draft is just it was a confusing one
that's all there is to be said about it
you know i understand addressing the
interior offensive line but i just don't
understand agree bay being in the super
bowl window right now
both matt lafleur and brian gudykoon
addressed the elephant in the room now
that there is a clock ticking an
expiration date applied to aaron rodgers
given the presence of jordan love whose
rights they will control for a maximum
of five years so at some point in the
next five years presumably they're going
to want to get a return
on the field not on the sideline on the
field for a guy they invested a first
round pick and a fourth round pick to
get here's what leflore had to say about
the situation aaron is a pro he's the
leader of our football team and i
anticipate that for a really long time i
hope he can play until he decides he
doesn't want to play
any more he is the one that leads us out
there i know he's going to be a great
mentor i don't know how good of a mentor
he's going to be because he may not want
to be right why do you want to help
prepare the guy who the more prepared he
is the more comfortable the team will be
in floating you on an iceberg if you're
aaron rodgers so look they're saying
what they have to say they have to say
this they're not going to come out and
say
what some people are going to think is
obvious from just looking at the names
of the draft picks they are playing life
without aaron rodgers and the question
is when does that begin chris
yeah well and i think that's just too
early i think that's the thing that
bothers me i mean you know
again i don't know if they're ever going
to see
any value or any assets in return for
somebody like jordan love i i that's
what i don't understand you know again
we're we're in the era of quarterbacks
play forever manning brees brady they're
they're still playing and they're pretty
high level rogers takes care of himself
you know his arm we know is an all-time
great arm for anybody to sit here and
think like oh aaron rodgers still won't
be dangerous like three or four years
from now that's insane i just have a
hard time believing that so what are
they gonna do you know get rid of them
then and then let let jordan love come
in as the quarterback for the fifth year
option here you know or or is he just
gonna end up becoming trade bait like
you know jimmy garoppolo where we go
well we had him he man he looked good
holding the clipboard all these years
good thing we wasted the first round
pick on him you know that's what i just
don't understand about this and you know
aaron rodgers he'll be a good tutor i
think he's going to be a good mentor to
jordan love mike i do i don't think i
think he kind of had it tough when he
came up under brett favre i don't you
know i've always heard brett favre
didn't really treat him great at first
until finally an understatement and
right you heard the same things right i
don't think aaron rodgers going to do
the same thing but do i think aaron
rodgers is going to try to stick it to
the green bay packers the set the first
chance he gets whatever way possible yes
i do
well and you know what he's going to
have an incentive to mentor jordan love
because the sooner jordan love is ready
the sooner he can go somewhere else so
in a roundabout way it helps aaron
rodgers to help jordan love if the
relationship at some level is now poison
for aaron rodgers and we know enough
about him to know he's not going to be
happy about this he's going to stew
about this it's a normal human reaction
and he may want out of there before they
want to move on here's what brian
goodikoon said about roger's future and
this comes from peter king in football
morning in america i'm very hopeful
aaron continues to play at a high level
for years to come i know a lot of people
are saying this puts a clock on aaron
but i don't see that at all we
prioritize the quarterback position and
have for a long time with this franchise
i remember one year in camp they had
brett favre ty detmer kurt warner and
maybe mark brunell it's one of the most
important positions in sports if you
don't have one you can't win i mean
let's be fair about this ty detmer was
not a good nfl quarterback even though
he was a great college quarterback
nobody knew who in the hell kurt warner
was at the time ditto for mark brunell
just because a guy develops elsewhere
doesn't mean that it was this jam-packed
superstar quarterback room nobody knew
it at the time that it was this room of
potential superstar quarterbacks so i
don't think that's an appropriate
comparison you mentioned jimmy garoppolo
i mean could the game here simply be
we have jordan love in the event that
aaron rodgers regresses this is our
insurance policy and maybe after three
years maybe during that fourth year
maybe even during that fifth year we
can't trade him
and replenish the first round pick i
mean the patriots got back a second
round pick the same second round pick
they gave up to get jimmy garoppolo
maybe the packers think they can get
back there one at some point down the
road for a jordan love who never plays i
don't know i don't know what the mindset
is right and what does that do what does
that do when you have aaron rodgers when
you're in the super bowl window and you
have four to five years to capitalize on
that for right now right i mean that's
where i don't understand it you know i
get it i think you're right it makes you
know better right now
exactly it makes you know better right
now and you know also when you just look
at the contract situation for aaron
rodgers and this too
you know i mean realistically just
looking at it
i mean there's no way green bay is going
to let him go even in the 2022 season
mike he's still got if they were going
to release him or find some way to part
ways it's going to be a 17 over 17
million dollars in dead cap money i mean
that's going to be hard to swallow for
our team anyways so that that would be
year four for jordan love no so we're
talking about three that's your three
year three sorry sorry yeah i've already
this is one of those you know how they
do the cooking show where they tell you
the recipe and then they just pull the
finished product out of the oven let me
give you the finished product because i
got the numbers here if they would trade
aaron rodgers right now which they're
not going to do it's a 45.9 million
dollar cap charge this year that's not
gonna happen if they trade him after
june 1
they would have 14.35 million hit the
cap this year 31.5 million hit the cap
next year that's not going to happen
either next year if they trade him
before june 1 it's that same 31.5
million dollar cap pit now they could
trade him after
june 1 next year and split the cap hit
over two years although i don't see that
transpiring you mentioned the
possibility of a 2022 trade that's two
years away capped charge of 17.2 million
that's really not all that much assuming
the salary cap is recovered from the
pandemic by then you have jordan love in
year three of his rookie deal so your
total quarterback investment will be not
all that out of whack because it's
whatever love is making plus 17 million
at the top of the depth chart i think
they could deal with that i think 2022
is the window to watch now here's the
problem can they get through two years
of aaron rodgers being ticked off being
salty i mean are they hoping that this
is almost like the julian edelman or the
west it's the wes welker effect i'm
getting my my undersized new england
slot receivers confused you always say
that they like wes welker to get pissed
off do they want aaron rodgers to get
pissed off and they think he's going to
find a higher level of performance the
next two years because he's got this guy
breathing down his throat almost like
what happened to tom brady we saw a
rebirth from tom brady
the fact that he had jimmy garoppolo
hovering over his shoulder well
there could be some you know
psychology to that i i don't doubt that
i don't think you draft the guy in the
first round just to prove that point
though i'll say that much i can
understand maybe wanting to bring
somebody in that maybe just lights a
little fire under his butt or just makes
them feel a little uncomfortable about
man you know this guy behind me he's got
a little talent you know but the big
thing is do we know he's going to be
pissed off of course we do i mean you
said it mike he's got a history like
this i love aaron rodgers i know he'll
be pissed off just from watching him
over years and then when your franchise
left tackle david bakitiari comes out
and basically says oh my gosh you know
rogers is going to be on fire he's going
to be pissed off at the world basically
you better watch out for him you know
that tells you that that is very real as
far as the way aaron rodgers acts and
what he portrays to the football team so
yeah he's going to be pissed and i would
think it's you know i don't think you're
going to have a lot of warm and cozy
conversations between him and goody and
and matt lefore this year i think he's
gonna be a little edge about him
but dude that's the thing do you want
that is it worth it
i don't know him
motivated to play at a higher level but
pissed off at everybody oh and also be a
good mentor to jordan love i i think
this is a very difficult balance for
anyone and i feel bad for aaron rodgers
i feel bad that he's got to deal with
this like if i'm aaron rodgers my
reaction is
haven't i done enough since i became the
starter in 2008 that you don't feel
compelled to manipulate me to play head
games with me screw this i want to play
for a team that is happy to have me it
doesn't feel like it has to play these
games to try to push my buttons to get
me to play at a higher level is it not
high enough would it not be a higher
level if you use a first round pick on a
damn receiver instead of a quarterback
who isn't going to play if i'm playing
i'd be upset and i would want out if i
was arizona and i'm not trying to cause
trouble here if this is a human reaction
if i'm aaron rodgers i don't want out in
two years i want out right now if you're
aaron rodgers at some point you just
want some receivers around you like the
other great quarterbacks in the history
of the sport have had around them i mean
joe montana steve young you know whether
you go brett favre elway you could just
go down the list at some point they had
big time talent around them peyton
manning
of course tom brady they've had weapons
they've had difference makers you know
they seem to neglect that too often in
green bay they had it early on in his
career and it's like these last four or
five years they're just like yeah he's
so good let's just make him carry the
team and we'll figure out ways to make
the team better in other areas where i
want to go that's cool but the team is
not that great in these other areas for
the fact that there's not a huge great
support system for rogers too so they're
not really holding up their bargain on
that end to where i go oh man yep he
doesn't have a lot of great receivers
but that defense it's a super bowl no
it's not it's good it's solid it's all
it's ever been so that that's where i
don't like it and you're right mike it
just seems like they've opened up a can
of worms here
ultimately as human beings we just want
to feel appreciated
regardless of what your job is
regardless of how much money you make
even if you're aaron rodgers at 32 and a
half million a year you just want to
feel appreciated and i think coming out
of this weekend he has reason to not
feel appreciated by the packers and he
has reason to think they're trying to
play some sort of game with him to try
to stoke him into being a better
quarterback when he should be able to
look at his body of work and say have i
not been good enough and speaking of
appreciation we appreciate chris who is
watching the show
in the uk greenwich mean time is the
time zone chris now we and now that i've
heard it i've kind of it's like yeah
i've heard that before but i never would
have remembered greenwich mean time but
it's now 12. thank you
chris hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports